1100 m² pour accueillir jusqu'à 80
réfugiés afghans la ville de guyancourt
est prête à mettre à disposition le
pavillon waldeck-rousseau en 2017 la
commune avait accueilli des migrants
évacués de la porte de la chapelle nous
pouvons assurer cet hébergement nous
pouvons installer des lits des lits de
camps bien évidemment nous avons un
certain nombre de structures à proximité
qui permettent effectivement aussi de
pouvoir se laver avec je pense notamment
au gymnase de l'aviation qui est à
proximité
nous avons un certain nombre de
structures à l'intérieur même du
bâtiment nous pouvons assurer aussi le
ravitaillement à la condition c'est que
nous soyons soutenu bien évidemment par
a minima ou l'état ou des associations
porteuses comme ça avait été le cas en
2017 comme françois morton plus de 50
élus du territoire indique vouloir
accueillir et accompagner les réfugiés
bertrand ou lyon le maire de magny les
hameaux twitté le 15 août il signera
ensuite une tribune initiée par david
hussein saïd j conseiller municipal
d'opposition d'epône ils ont envie de se
mobiliser parce que ce n'est pas juste
une signature sur une tribune c'est
aussi un engagement puisque beaucoup
d'élus ont déjà pris des engagements
chaque commune peut le faire voilà à
différentes échelles bien sûr va pas
demander autant de réfugiés iphone que
sur que surmonte par exemple voilà il
faut que ce soit fait
à taille humaine il faut y associer les
habitants des associations et tout ceux
et celles qui souhaitent y participer le
premier ministre jean castex a annoncé
que la france allait cesser les
évacuations le 27 août jeudi 26 août un
double attentat suicide a fait 85 morts
au sein de l'aéroport de kaboul la
capitale afghane